vous savez quoi je pense que ça devrait
faire une vidéo sur celle oui ça féret
xiaomi a encore frappé xiaomi 9900 1909
des pros et maintenant le minot flight
ça fait beaucoup 2009 chez oh oui mais
bon pourquoi pas la stratégie est très
cavalière ça je vais tout vous expliquer
maintenant
[Musique]
m
en nous
[Musique]
moi ça va tout mais qu'on écrans full
moon dans un bras blue maintenance et
ses plaisirs torse n'aurait pas vu toi
moi ça fait quoi ça fait 2 5 c'était
toujours trop longtemps moi je vais
manger bon et catherine bon ben moi
j'aime autant pourquoi ces petits
lancement du bit of light n'a rien ça
fait beaucoup 2009 en fait ouais c'est
ça bon ben voila comme tu disais quand
on aime on ne compte pas uniquement que
là bas c'est ça c'est ça c'est bon on va
voir si les gens à aider à s'y retrouver
franchement ils sont pas franchement qui
est sympa avec moi je suis sympa je
découpe et hdd est reconnu comme
d'habitude les contours de la tête le
but du brésilien l'a fait
renseigne-toi baril paparazzi tattoo
sein desquelles les téléphones à
photographier ça vous transforme et ça
vous rend complètement fou les toits
guillaume toute façon là va y avoir de
la bouffe et les téléphones et aux
enjeux mon petit chien on va plus
invitée après celle pas du tout pas du
tout l'état des rues menu pas regarder
parce qu'on joue pas oui saumon grillé
mariné soja citronnelle crème d'avocat
citron vert pickles radis rouges suprême
de volaille fermière oignons caramélisés
mousseline le patates douces et jus de
rôti et à l'un des siens et les sublimes
tartelettes mouche fraises et pistaches
je suis le petit gibbon téléspectateurs
on a un bon public aujourd'hui
bienvenue à toi je suis ça va partout ce
type c'est fini ça résonne quand même un
policier un chien mais nous a présenté
un tout nouveau smartphone c'est le
mineur flight qui vient s'inscrire dans
la gamme alors je sais ça fait un peu
compliqué
tous les smartphones sont cette année on
la dénomination mis neuf tous à quelque
chose près le mx3 sa peine pas mimi hx9
s'appelle le x3 mais il ya beaucoup 2009
alors dans cette gamme c'est des fois un
peu compliqué de comprendre comment ça
marche c'est compliqué de s'y retrouver
mais bon justement on est là pour ça ne
te regarder chaque vidéo vous
comprendrez comment s'articulent et
justement on a un nouveau smartphone
c'est le mil neuf light
très clairement la par rapport aux mille
neuf c'est le modèle un peu plus light
mais qui par contre c'est franchement le
job je vais vous expliquer comment ça
marche après je peux comprendre que du
point de vue consommateur c'est
compliqué de se dire alors attends moi
je veux bien smartphone de chez omis la
marque a l'air cool par contre je sais
pas du tout lequel prend soin du tout
par quel bout le prendre parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup et beaucoup trop c'est
clair l'idée c'est quoi c'est quoi la
strate derrière tout ça c'est quoi la
stratégie de schumi et bien c'est
simplement d'être présent sur tous les
segments de prix à quelque chose près
pour pouvoir vous proposer toujours
introduites shiomi
face à un autre produit l'idée
aujourd'hui avec ce smartphone là c'est
proposer une fois de plus un excellent
rapport qualité prix et ce smartphone là
il fait trois promesses essentiel la
toute première c'est la photo un
excellent photophone tout cas ce que
nous promet chemin-là c'est que la prise
en main je vais depuis tout à l'heure le
smartphone ne s'est pas le test on fera
dans quelques jours donc vous invite à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
le deuxième point très important c'est
un design hyper sexy toujours dans l'air
du temps avec un dos en verre avec des
jolis petits réflexes pas si vous voyez
bien comme ça en tout cas croyez moi il
est très sympa on va se mettre de côté
dans quelques instants
on va le film et du dessous vous allez
voir il franchement cool et puis le
troisième point c'est une grosse
autonomie grâce à une grosse batterie un
smartphone endurance vais pouvoir garder
emmener partout l'otan avec vous donc ça
c'est plutôt cool première chose qu'on
va garder un petit peu ce qui se passe
du côté du design du point de vue de la
face avant on n'a rien complètement
dingue on va retrouver un petit peu
cette petite encoche là ils ont très
bien caché
c'est très malin avec le fond d'écran
comme ça mais croyez moi vous avez une
encoche gouttes de voiliers elle
apparaît juste là donc là vous êtes
tranquille vous avez votre petite
encoche bon design assez simple on a un
écran de 6 39 pouces diagonale c'est un
écran samsung qui a priori protéger
contre la lumière bleue qui a une
certification allemande
je ne connaissais pas cette
certification v2 pourquoi pas design
assez simple après vous avez vos boutons
ici pour monter le volume le décès le
bouton pour l'allumer haut parleur mono
le micro qui se cassent la de la
recharge ici en usb tissé sur le côté si
vous avez votre tiroir de cartes sim
prise jack qui est concerné ça c'est
plutôt cool micro pour la réduction de
bruit ici de l'infrarouge à l'arrière
triple capteur photo up juste là une
première caméra celle à 48 mégapixels
c'est la sony et 1580 de joie parlant
quelques instants vous avez deux autres
capteurs un capteur qui va servir pour
la profondeur de chance un capteur de 2
mégapixels et l'autre c'est un ultra
grand angle 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à 118
degrés voilà un peu pour le côté
esthétique élan après ce qui est très
sympa c'est qu'on a effectivement
s'était fait un peu 3d voyez avec
différents reflet c'est pas si ça sort
baigne à côté un peu arc en ciel c'est
pas mal d'années alors il ya différentes
versions moi j'ai la version blanche
il existe un modèle déry est également
un modèle bleu grosse nouveauté et ça
c'est plutôt intéressant et c'est
vachement cool pour qu'on puisse se
soigner
c'est l'arrivée du logo xiaomi parce
qu'effectivement ce le constat que fait
chironi france et que le logo me est
très bien connue et reconnue lorsque
vous êtes en asie et notamment en chine
par contre dès vous arriver en france
et bien c'est beaucoup moins connus ou
moins facile à vendre là par contre vous
avez votre logo qui a parlé et qui a un
vrai sens de vous montrer dans quelques
instants
smartphone qui est assez léger qui fait
179 g vous avez un corning gorilla glass
5 à l'avant comme à l'arrière qui vous
avez ici votre capteur d'empreinte
digitale qui les rouilles assez
rapidement l'écran c'est donc une dalle
samsung qu'on va retrouver dessus tout
simplement parce que ça me souffler
partie des deux constructeurs jeudi en
gros gros qu'on va pouvoir retrouver sur
android samsung et lg fond d écran
d'excellente qualité donc sur un
smartphone de chez lui sur ce modèle en
tout cas vous avez un écran de samsung
6,39 pouces avec une résolution de 2300
ses marques et en bas je ne connais pas
par coeur de 1340 par 1080 pixels à 403
pixels par pouce côté audio alors de ce
que j'ai pu écouter comme ça très
rapidement mais sans leurs parents lors
du test l'audio est pas demain qu'on
n'est pas sur un smartphone hyper haut
de gamme
on a un haut parleur mono ça sans
cracher un peu de son je vais pas donner
de résultat tout de suite
contre truc est vachement intéressant
c'est le fait que vous ayez la prise
jack qu'ils soient conservés ici avec un
signal à y restent donc dus l'audio
haute définition ça également je vous
dis alors que je testerai un peu plus
londres après un top-case un passé qui
s'il a en fait le petit logo shiomi
c'est la nouvelle lettre de notification
c'est à dire qu'elle va pouvoir
s'allumer et changer de couleur en
fonction des actions que vous allez
faire vous en montre une par hasard je
vais le charger et bien là voyez hop je
sais pas si c'est bien évident à cause
de la lumière environnante
en gros elle est allumée en jaune j'ai
coupé toutes les lumières que vous
puissiez vous en rendre compte voyez ici
elle est allumée en jaune est en fait
vous allez avoir différentes
possibilités
lorsqu'elle est en jaune si vous êtes en
train de le charger lorsqu'elle est en
rouge si vous écoutez de la musique
lorsqu'elle est en bleu c'est vous avez
une notification et lorsqu'elle est en
jaune clignotants et bien c'est vous est
tout simplement un appel entrant côté
performances on a un instinct dragonne
710 sais pas si ça vous parle c'est un
des processeurs milieu haut de gamme de
qualcomm qui écoute qui marchent
vachement bien qui est couplé à 6 giga
de ram pour apporter de la fluidité et
côté stockage vous allez soit 64 giga de
stockage soit 128 giga de stockage et de
extensible jusqu'à 250 gigas grâce à une
carte microsd
mais là où gros focus effet de la partie
selon lui c'est sur la batterie 4030
humiliant père heures ils nous disent
que c'est beaucoup plus que sur le mil
neuf pour voir qu'on a mis 9 lite qui a
une plus grosse batterie
camille 9 why not avoir effectivement
s'il en dur en tout cas ce que nous
annoncions miss et jusqu'à deux journaux
mattrick pas deux jours de matt rimer
jusqu'à bien évidemment parce que ça
dépend une fois de plus de vos usages si
vous bourrine énormément à jouer un jeu
toute la journée vous nous traitez deux
jours vous les aurez pas si par contre
vous avez un usage un peu plus raisonner
un peu plus cool
on peut y arriver ça je donnerai mon
résultat dans quelques jours lorsque je
leur ai testé point qu'il coule
si vous avez un chargeur de 18 watts qui
est inclus en natif dans la boîte et on
nous annonce une charge de 0 à 40 3%
points très précis en seulement 30
minutes mais je crois que l'effet le
plus what the fuck se situe ici au
niveau de la caméra alors comme je le
disais vous avez un triplement des
caméras ça vous aura pas échappé vous
avez compté jusqu'à 3 jusque là tout va
bien
quarante huit mégapixels salah sony mx 5
182 tout simplement parce que lorsque
vous avez un qualcomm instinct dragonne
710 et non pas 1 855 il ya vous ne
pouvez avoir
et ce qui est déjà très très bien tu ne
sont ni mx 5 182 et non pas la 586 me
direz vous pourquoi la seule différence
si vous ne pouvez pas filmer en 4k à 60
images par seconde
dans quatre cas à 30 images par seconde
ce qui est déjà extrêmement bien est ce
qu'on a besoin de filmer en cas de cas
60 images par seconde pas nécessairement
il ouvre à f 1.79 l'ultra grand temps où
il met cap xs en 1918 degrés je voulais
10,2 mégapixels pour les faits beaucoup
et je voulais dire et donc filmé jusqu'à
30 images par seconde en 4k ça paraît
assez logique à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de celle fille qui est planqué
justice il a regardé hop elle est cachée
juste là 30 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.0 paulien film et jusqu'en 1080p à 30
images par seconde why not mais là où
est le truc un petit peu what the fuck
vous allez voir c'est c'est juste
hallucinant vous et dans la galerie
c'est une photo que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure depuis la fin du studio cherchez
pas il fait beau je sais on à paris fait
beau c'est incroyable mais pourtant
c'est vrai vous allez cliquer ici là
c'est un petit baguette magique vous
allez sur on cherche filtre et dans
filtre vous avez dans ciel tout au bout
et là c'est là que la magie opère
regarder ça c'est le ciel tel qu'il est
fait et bien est-ce que vous devrez
rajouter un petit arc en ciel paf on en
a reconsidéré la sepa par février ça m'a
un petit peu cropettes le noir il a un
petit peu de mal ça me fait des petites
incruste mais bon imaginez vous avez un
ciel parfait vous êtes en vacances vous
avez en ciel horrible il ya en fait ce
que vous voulez vous pouvez rajouter un
ciel un peu plus éclatant carrément un
crépuscule mais c'est je trouve ça
vraiment hyper me voir parce que votre
même les couleurs sur l'immeuble en face
c'est hyper bien fait un petit coucher
de soleil si ça vous tente
ou alors pourquoi pas rajouter des
nuages qui vous lie à bon allez il fait
beau mais on pas non plus trop vous
dégoûter ou alors carrément ensoleillé
comme ça et je vous rappelle que la
photo de base c'est ça donc c'est juste
hallucinant et après prévenir moduler
voulait s'appuyer dessus
et là vous venez oui vous vous êtes un
peu plus beau un peu moins beau fait
apparaître vos nuageux vous faites comme
vous voulez enfin le truc est juste
d'agde donc du coup vous pouvez faire
croire ce que vous voulez pour vous et
partir en vacances en bretagne en plein
hiver et faire croire que vous avez un
ciel incroyable bond mise à part vous
allez vous cahiers les bonbons
directement sur la plage en plein hiver
en bretagne mais sinon en tout cas ça
fait son petit effet le côté positif
dans tout ça c'est qu'il n'aura jamais
été aussi simple date instagram heures
vous n'avez plus qu'à prendre votre
photo ou vous soyez l'américain temps
horrible
vous mettez en maillot de bain et vous
fait la photo léchée parfait c'est un
petit peu au web the fuck mais c'est
rigolo
pourquoi pas alors il ya plein de choses
qui ont été faites au niveau de l'est le
go on en reparlera un peu plus tard
lorsque je le testerai je ramasse au
smartphone qui est par terre je ramasse
mais notent qu'ils sont par terre mais
bon moi je pense qu'en tout cas le
smartphone est assez cool comme ça
on tourne bien évidemment sur me white
bien évidemment sur un an dour et vous
avez en plus un thème sombre directement
si vous voulez économiser de la batterie
pu éviter de fatiguer les yeux pourquoi
pas vous avez du nfc et c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible à partir
du 23 septembre au tarif 2 je vous le
dis parce que j'ai appris par coeur vous
devez donc de config 6 + 64 ou 6e +128
la 6e 64 est annoncé au tarif de 299
euros mais parce que toujours à mes
jusqu'à fin fin suite à fin octobre
vous avez une exclu avec cdiscount vous
pouvez retrouver au tarif de 299 euros
uniquement chez cdiscount pendant tout
le mois d'octobre c'est l'anniversaire
cdiscount va pouvoir faire de la pub
mais je vous lis ou pas vert uniforme 3
faire si vous l'achetez why not et si
vous vous connectez alors attention faut
vraiment faire super gaffe est le
premier ou la première le lundi ou le
jeudi entre 17 heures et 19 heures c'est
très restrictif je sais eh bien vous
pourrez la voir au talent et de 269
euros tout ça dans la limite des stocks
disponibles
autant dire que un peu compliqué mais
bon pourquoi parlez vous déjà fait
l'opération il ya quelques mois avec le
minatd et sané cartonné et elle
reconduite avec un priori un peu plus de
stock et si vous voulez avoir ensuite le
modèle en 6 +128 giga vous pouvez le
trouver à 329 euros
pas pour l'instant bientôt dans
différentes enseignes
donc voilà à vous de dire ce que vous en
pensez comment vous trouvez vous ce 1
min flight bien pas bien séduisant pas
séduisant qu'est ce que vous pensez
peut-être que cela était dire pour
rallier un peu triché sur le ciel pour
carrément tricher sur le ciel est ce que
vous trouvez intéressant qu'est ce que
vous pensez du prix est ce que vous
pensez qu'une fois de plus ils ont mis à
frapper fort et est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain d'ici là soyez sages soyez
sages
moi c'est ça portez vous bien je vous
embrasse ciao